democrats calls to defund the police
backfiring in liberal cities across the
country
many places seeing a surge in violent
crime like in new york city where
murders are up over 40 percent
philadelphia is reportedly on track to
break a record for homicides as well
and atlanta mayor keisha lance bottoms
coming under fire for her inability to
address a crime rape
and she is now asking citizens for
suggestions
on how to stop it joe biden reportedly
has a plan to address this chaos
by using the doj to police the police
jason i'm going to start with you will
policing the police
stop crime well look there are policemen
that need to have review and there are
bad cops out there
and no doubt about it but when you lead
with that
when your person that's the vice
presidential pick
uh kamala harris is out there playing
bail to get people that have been
you know accused of writing and and and
doing those types and looting and that
sort of thing to get them out of jail
they go back out on the streets as fast
as possible
when you support policies in these big
cities with
like no cash bail things like that
you're going to see the the morale for
police just plummet
in new york city alone the number of
shootings compared to last year
is double double well guess what when
you take a billion dollars out of the
police budget you take them out of the
school system
and you belittle these police officers
time and time again guess what you're
gonna have
record high number of people retiring
and you're gonna see crime go up it's
one of those
well duh what'd you think was gonna
happen and as long as these democratic
policies are in place
the situation's going to get worse well
jess you have people like house majority
whip james clyburn who said that the
defund the police rhetoric
was responsible for democrats losing so
badly
down ballot so why haven't democrats
learn their lesson
well i think the democrats that won
their races have learned their lesson
look at joe biden who said from the
get-go i absolutely have no intention of
defending the police and it's frankly a
really dumb idea
nobody wants it especially the
communities where the police are there's
always the highest approval rating
actually
for police in areas where there's more
crime and that makes a tremendous amount
of sense
so i don't see that from people in
positions of power you don't have any
tape of nancy pelosi saying to fund the
police
that's a far left trope and it did hurt
us in those races i would
encourage everyone to listen to abigail
spanberger who barely won reelection
talking about how discussions of
socialism and defending the police hurt
her in her own race and she almost lost
because of it
and i i think that it's incredibly
harmful especially because it isn't true
and it's not a democratic party is he
not making police a target by saying we
need to police the police right now
is that is that the issue when you're
saying crime
like new york city i i don't think that
that's the issue i think it speaks to
what jason is saying and biden's been
clear about this
as well that he doesn't think it's a
blanket statement about police officers
that they're all like derek chovin
but that we need to make sure that bad
apples are pushed out
and i think that it's important also
that we acknowledge the circumstances
right now
the economic downturn people have not
been
in work folks are at home and you are
going to see surges
respond to that what we just heard from
jess is it is it the economic
downturn what's behind this spike in
murders and crime that we're seeing in
so many of america's cities
it's bad left-wing liberal policies put
into place by the people who were
elected
so the people in new york city and now
los angeles county
just to name two places are getting what
they voted for
here in new york city it's hell on earth
earlier this year
both kamala harris by the way and joe
biden proposed getting rid of cash bail
new york did that where you were
arrested for manslaughter
you didn't have to post bail arrested
for arson
you didn't have to put up bail arrested
for assaulting a 11 year old child
you didn't have to put up bail it was so
bad and crime spiked so quickly earlier
this year
they had to reform it in a matter of
months
but what you're still seeing in new york
city because those elected leaders from
the governor andy cuomo
on down to the mayor of bill de blasio
and also
the d.a uh here in new york city
they turn their backs on the police and
so you've had a spike in retirements and
it's not just shootings murders up 39
in the last year here in new york uh
grand
auto grand larceny auto up 68
uh it and you have no way of defending
yourself because you know what the
second amendment doesn't exist here for
law-abiding citizens the people who have
the guns are
rich and famous people who know folks in
power and
criminals i'm thinking about carrying a
hockey stick next time
just in case i get chased again which
has actually happened
yeah lawrence i want to get you in here
before we have to go so joe biden's got
a real mixed record here
he was the you know spearhead of the
1994 bill now he's saying police
officers need to be pleased
i can't keep track what kind of where do
you think he's going to stand on all
this
as an incoming president we'll have to
wait and see because he's become a
political chameleon
depending on who's in the room you'll
get a different answer from him but
guys i've been reporting on this way
before the pandemic i've seen
more blood still on the ground i've
interviewed
families that kids have been shot and i
don't mean like
a 17 year old i mean like six year olds
or five years old
and it happens every single week and i
think the reason why we continue to have
this issue between
whether it is the violence that are
happening on the street or the disarray
between the police departments
is because everyone wants to choose a
side of this debate
um we are all created equal and
government needs to
acknowledge that when dealing with these
crisis
so what do i mean when people are being
shot or gunned down in the street
the state needs to go after them when
there is abuse of power by the state
then they need to go after them without
fear or favor and when law
officers law enforcement officers are
attacked simply because they wear blue
and do their job and because people
don't like them people
need to be prosecuted everyone wants to
choose a bucket when all
buckets by the constitution are created
equal
tonight can i just say one thing i just
want to mention the name of kennedy
maxie
she was seven years old and she was
struck by a bullet
when she was it passed through her car
she was out christmas shopping
with her mother and her aunt she was in
um succumbed to the injuries on saturday
that was in atlanta let's name all of
those people who've lost their lives
because of senseless violence and
because police
are people don't have their backs good
point jagen